- [Instructor] What we
have written here are two
of the most useful derivatives
to know in calculus.
If you know that the
derivative of sine of x
with respect to x is cosine of x
and the derivative of cosine of x
with respect to x is negative sine of x,
that can empower you to do many more,
far more complicated derivatives.
But what we're going to do in this video
is dig a little bit deeper
and actually prove this first derivative.
I'm not gonna prove the second one.
You can actually use it,
using the information we're
going to do in this one,
but it's just to make you feel good that
someone's just not making this up,
that there is a little bit of mathematical
rigor behind it all.
So let's try to calculate it.
So the derivative with
respect to x of sine of x,
by definition, this is
going to be the limit
as delta x approaches zero
of sine
of x plus
delta x minus
sine of x,
all of that over delta,
all of that over delta x.
This is really just the slope
of the line between the point
x comma sine of x and x plus delta x
comma sine of x plus delta x.
So how can we evaluate this?
Well, we can rewrite
sine of x plus delta x
using our angle addition formulas
that we learned during
our trig identities.
So this is going to be the same thing
as the limit
as delta x approaches zero.
I'll write, rewrite this using
our trig identity as cosine,
as cosine
of x
times sine
of delta x
plus sine
of x
times cosine
of delta x.
And then we're going to
subtract this sine of x up here
minus sine of x,
all of that over,
let me see if I can draw a
relatively straight line,
all of that over
delta x.
So this can be rewritten
as being equal to the limit
as delta x approaches zero of,
let me write this part in red,
so that would be cosine of x, sine
of delta x,
all of that over delta x.
And then that's going to be plus,
I'll do all of this in orange,
all I'm doing is
I have the sum of things
up here divided by delta x,
I'm just breaking it up
a little bit, plus sine
of x,
cosine of delta x
minus sine of x,
all of that over delta x.
And remember, I'm taking the limit
of this entire expression.
Well, the limit of a sum is
equal to the sum of the limits.
So this is going to be equal to,
I'll do this first part in red,
the limit
as delta x approaches zero of,
let's see I can rewrite
this as cosine of x
times sine
of delta x
over delta x
plus
the limit
as delta x approaches zero
of, and let's see I can
factor out a sine of x here.
So it's times
sine
of x.
I factor that out,
and I'll be left with a cosine
of delta x minus one,
all of that over
delta x.
So that's this limit.
And let's see if I can
simplify this even more.
Let me scroll down a bit.
So this left-hand
expression I can rewrite.
This cosine of x has nothing to do with
the limit as delta x approaches zero,
so we can actually take
that outside of the limit.
So we have the cosine of x times the limit
as delta x approaches zero
of sine of delta x
over delta x.
And now we need to add this thing,
and let's see how I could write this.
So I have a sine of x here.
But actually, let me rewrite
this a little bit differently.
Cosine of delta x minus one,
that's the same thing as
one minus cosine of delta x
times negative one.
And so you have a sine of
x times a negative one.
And since the delta x has
nothing to do with the sine of x,
let me take that out, the
negative and the sine of x.
So we have minus sine of x
times the limit
as delta x approaches zero of,
what we have left over is
one minus cosine of delta x
over
delta x.
Now, I'm not gonna do it in this video.
In other videos, we will
actually do the proof.
But in other videos we have shown,
using the squeeze theorem,
or sometimes known as
the sandwich theorem,
that the limit is delta x approaches zero
of sine of delta x over delta x,
that this is equal to one.
And we also show in another video,
and that's based on the idea
that this limit is equal to one,
that this limit right over
here is equal to zero.
And so what we are then left with,
and I encourage you to watch the videos
that prove this and this,
although these are really useful limits
to know in general in calculus,
that what you're gonna be
left with is just cosine of x
times one minus sine of x times zero.
Well, all of this is just gonna go away,
and you're gonna have,
that is going to be equal to cosine of x.
And you are done.